i forgot how cool that looks this is my
life something will come out and
everybody in the world will send me the
same thing
you can see the bones through his hand
there the light of the explosion is so
bright i was about to say is it wires
but then i'm like i mean literally what
else could it be
[Laughter]
today's episode is brought to you by
squarespace stick around to the end to
see how you can get 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain
hey everyone welcome to visual effects
artists react today we have a very
special guest none other than captain
dissolutions intern
alan hi everybody i'm happy to be here
uh the captain sends his best but
obviously he couldn't make time but i'm
here on his behalf and i i hope to do a
good job you're still unpaid right
unfortunately yes it's been only about
14 years so the captain says i'm coming
up on a review period when i can finally
start talking about maybe having a per
diem from my 24 hour shifts yeah
that'd be good it's not like i do all
the work for him or anything i don't
want you guys to think that i i do do
all the editing and all the analyzing
and all the script writing so you know
it's a collaborative effort
[Laughter]
in turn or not it is an honor to have
you join us on the couch i've been
watching your videos for years i think
you're an amazing educator communicator
and you do dang good vfx i'm excited for
everyone watching because the requests
have been like relentless
i'm here internet bullies
i hope you're happy it's cool like
there's not a lot of other people also
like breaking stuff down like this yeah
i do feel at home i've never really been
like among people who are on the same
wavelengths about the way i look at vfx
and the way i consume this kind of stuff
well let's jump into some clips let's
look at stuff together yeah let's do it
when this baby hits 88 miles per hour
you're gonna see some serious [ __ ] i'm
surprised we haven't actually reacted to
back to the future yet
look at that trust in his invention and
willing to sacrifice a high school kid
if it goes wrong and himself
[Music]
i forgot how cool that looks like the
energy that it's like running into like
it feels like it's like piercing through
something it's really well animated this
is all hand drawn by the artist that did
call the lightning as well i kind of
missed that hand-drawn glowy energy look
my childhood memory of seeing this for
the first time wasn't like oh that's
fake it was like it's cool how he can
just be cool about fire hitting his leg
like it didn't cross my mind that it's
fake well because they have that one
shot of like what seems to be dummies
yeah yeah i think it's just like they
probably just built just the legs of
them
yeah if you think about it it's kind of
a funny shot to just like drop in in a
sequence like this
it's like a huge night sequence and like
one shot is just them on a blue screen
instead of just being there i think
they're standing on glass so that they
could have that reflection they're
actually on mylar that kind of
reflective stuff you make for balloons
oh okay so it's like that's why it's a
little bit diffused looking that makes
sense it's really funny like how crude
this explosion looks now
like they just play it halfway and they
play it backwards you see the effect
they're trying to go for that's
replicated now it's like that kind of
turbulent
like getting sucked into something
effect but it does look a little bit
weird now
it's strange because people think of it
as like an effects movie but really it's
like not really that much going on it's
just a good movie and the effects are
used in like a really smart way do you
know there's actually only 27 vfx shots
in the entire film whoa yeah i knew it
was low but not that low that's amazing
so maybe that's why we haven't looked at
it yet yeah i heard that most of it is
just like optical lightning
when they're coming up with the look of
time travel from back to future one
terminator had just come out and robert
zemeckis was saying like no electricity
i don't want any electricity in my
effects it's got to be something else i
want it to be ugly i don't want it to be
pretty you're piercing time you're
breaking it open well what's interesting
i heard him in interviews say you know
he's not into kind of going back and
cleaning things up fixing things up like
in part two after the hoverboard chase
when the bad guys are crashing through
the glass of the courthouse you could
clearly see some like flying rigs
[Music]
yeah right there you can see a little
bit of her wire there so they're not
painting out wires they didn't do it
originally when the movie came out so
like that shot where they're all flying
towards the camera this is either
cleaned up recently or the cables are
that fine like how thin of a cable does
that have to be because every single
time i've took string or thread or tried
to go if they used to do it like this it
should be invisible i film it and then i
the string's there
you see a string it's like i've never
understood quite how
people have got that effect to actually
function speaking of very thin wires
it's a known enough fact like the david
copperfield illusion of like the flying
man and how that's done that doesn't
involve being in a really
precarious like wiring situation vfx
artists react to live magic
but the thing is like what's the
difference like why are we allowed to
ruin vfx shots for people but not magic
shows they're the same thing
just one's being filmed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
flight it's really well done yeah i mean
having looked at wire work in movies you
know people doing stunts and all that
kind of stuff the amount of control that
we are seeing here is actually really
impressive it was really smooth i was
about to say is it wires but then i'm
like i mean literally what else could it
be
it's like an array oh wow
that's a lot of wires they're all one
millimeter one millimeter it's just like
the thinnest the skinniest of wires well
it's also like i'm saying we have a
moving background yeah i mean there's a
lot optically done to help hide things
yeah like standard definition
is helping
[Music]
well come on i mean come on he just went
they proved it
look there's nothing beneath and nothing
above
just pass this ring over you
yeah well that proves there's no wire
look at him he's just like i did it
i can fly
it's funny all the clips i brought today
are people flying on wires
that looks like it'd be a lot of fun i
know i see that's what i was thinking
it's like the effects are cool but also
i'm like this is actually kind of
capturing that weird dreamlike feeling
of flying around it's pretty cool
i'm guessing it's like really good wire
work in studio and then just cg mockups
of them that are you know making the
environment interaction so there's some
stuff you look at you're like this is
very cg you can tell there's some
compositing happening especially here at
the end but if you go back to the very
first shot the shot of this wave coming
i was like whoa that kind of was that a
cg thing it like it's very cg-esque
there's a helicopter flying over the
field right there oh really so that's
real grass movement and i was like wait
the amount of distance they're covering
is beyond comprehension sometimes are
they just dangling on a freaking chopper
uh no
they're actually doing this oh really
they have like these like 150 foot
cranes oh wow it's just like mega mega
mega level wire work the cranes are so
big like they're not even in any of
these shots look at this like where are
they basically they're just creating
these zip lines that are
spanning hundreds of feet with these
massive cranes and then a ton of paint
outs ton of background replacements all
the basic stuff that's how they get you
they just did it for real
they just did it and they stumped me
they were so used to seeing like the
spectacular be faked these days that
when the spectacular turns out to be
real it's very refreshing we're talking
about visual magic tricks you did send
over a few
tick tocks
that i think are worth taking a look at
this is my life really where something
will come out and everybody in the world
will send me the same thing sometimes
it's easy to explain but sometimes it's
like something like this this is my
bluetooth hose and a lot of people
thought i was using a green screen or
like the water was fake but it's legit
just this is funny i remember seeing
this this is it was like the bluetooth
hose this is like the follow-up video he
made after people were like oh fake the
first video is a little bit i feel like
you can hypothesize what was done and
this one he's like okay they're on to me
so he did some things differently so i'm
just gonna say right now the first one
is a paint out it's a hose paint up look
at the way he's holding it i can feel
the weight in his hand yeah i think the
second one his follow-up i think he's
comping in the stream of water there
that's like either like an element or
like a particle or maybe he just turned
on the hose and filmed it against black
and like when he puts his hand in front
of it there first off we don't see his
hand again we can't tell it's wet
actually wet from it and we're just
seeing this diversion and the way that
the stream starts it's a little too like
easy like it doesn't drip on his fingers
yeah that might be right but they might
have also just like it's drilled in and
installed some kind of side inlet for
the water if you look at how he's
holding it there could be a little thing
going between his pointer and his middle
finger there along the back of his hand
because he knows it just sticks there
right yeah he's holding it in a very
particular way if there's a side hose in
that last dropping shot he transitions
into one that has a normal hose so that
it can land properly so i guess there's
an actual behind the scenes of the hose
oh let's see how we did so it's actually
not bluetooth oh
oh fingers
so much simpler but that doesn't explain
how i was able to drop the hose and have
nothing connected to it so to do that
first i took a video of just the grass i
got that right too he transitions from
one to another that's good magicianship
i mean it's basically being a magician
and what happens now is that like this
couple of videos blew up and now he's
gonna have to be like feeling the
pressure of coming up with something of
equal he's at the hardware store just
like walking around what else like
nervously pacing down the aisles of home
depot i need ideas people what's the
smallest nail gun you have
i mean but you know that's a thing
though that's the thing
you can make a career out of that kids
[Music]
oh boy this one i've seen this one
what's happening the promise of 3d tvs
finally realized so have you looked at
any behind the scenes on this no i'm
curious to see but i mean i could tell
either a lot of really cool 3d tracking
going on or everything's cg and there's
just like bits of the person being
compton i actually know how this is done
so yeah also yeah excuse me sam wickert
who's that guy right there was actually
over here about two months ago and this
is a video they had just dropped and he
gave us the rundown sam take it away
uh
there's a hole in the wall
big surprise right it's a set with a
hole and they track the camera and he
goes through it nice pretty sure they
did this with unreal it feels unreally
yeah i'm pretty sure they uh even use
their virtual camera tracking system for
it simple right highly technical and
well executed it looks so cool
speaking of first person shots you guys
want to deviate from tick tock and get
back to old school movies oh boy
doom 2005
wow
they're emulating video game look really
well by just making everything out of
cardboard i guess
this is way slower than i remember it
being i thought this was like really
high intensity like running around
it has that ultra slow down quality to
it like make sure you see this thing we
worked on
he fell onto my trap
oh no whoa
you can see the bones through his hand
there you notice that the light of the
explosion is so bright yeah x-ray bones
will never go out of style
here we go now now it's getting like
kind of moving normally wait is this
because it's 100 cg now it's got to be
that's probably why where it's like okay
for the end fight let's just do it all
cg and that way we don't have to have
like the steadicam operator like
carefully tiptoeing
another interesting decision is that
they filmed the gun separately the gun's
not part of the shots it's like green
screen element i guess that makes sense
to do probably been kind of crazy to try
to have the gun there the whole time
yeah it's one of those sequences where
like the vfx aren't actually bad or
anything just
the sequence itself feels odd and a
little outdated but that's sometimes
what happens when you pioneer things and
you try stuff out for the first time
that's right everybody was complaining
about how the polar express looks creepy
but i'm sorry they were breaking new
ground
so this is the part where i usually ask
you to subscribe i'm going to do just
that please subscribe to captain
distillations channel
thank you if you enjoy visual effects rs
react just imagine the production
quality ramped up ten-fold in the
writing actually
being written
versus improv on the spot yeah if you
want a non-improvised version of visual
effects artists react check out his
channel the lore the deep lore there's
like deep captain disillusion lore and
if you're watching this and you're not
subscribed to this then that doesn't
make any sense subscribe right now right
right there
thank you is there an effect in one of
your videos that you're particularly
proud of oh geez you'll break the
illusion of me seeming like a good vfx
artist where like all i'm making all i
make is like goofy and janky i mean
that's the exact same boat
[Laughter]
every video has a half-life of relevance
and i admit i don't always get to all of
them in time while being somewhat like
inspired by like 80s and 90s aesthetic i
also feel like i just rely on it
everything looks 80s and 90s when you
work on it and then you just refine it
to the point of today and sometimes i
just don't do it or like i don't have
the time to do it and i just stop at
that place where it's like oh this looks
a little bit old-school and i kind of
like it
what they did was film
i love the attention to detail you put
into your work yeah like everything from
at the very beginning when you're like
you're talking on the screen it breaks
and the shadow of it is also broken like
that's the kind of stuff that most
people wouldn't take the time to do uh
a lot of these have been covered way
back i sometimes have episodes like this
where like stuff starts slowly happening
and the environment changes you know
it's like little things like
eventually the room keeps getting more
and more degraded i gotta take it easier
on the people around me like friends and
interns and such and your 3d work is
also really good you hit the whole
breadth of things compositing animation
motion graphics writing yeah this looks
great well thank you it's no doom 2005
it does the job yeah i know it's
projection mapping and that the real
ladder is quickly swung in and out at
certain moments even the corridor crew
figured that much out
vfx reactor vmfx react
was i saying nice things or bad things
you're making fun of our our reactions
faces
we have to remember to get some reaction
faces for thumbnails and stuff i want to
like do full ren like
no
that's a good red impression
you've got the ball pistols and
everything
[Music]
at the beginning of this whole sequence
i'm like flying so i just like sat on a
apple box and did
real old school remember love with your
heart use your head for everything else
captain disillusion that broom shot that
was good
look at this look at this where's that
broom coming from well do you want to
have a chance to hypothesize about it
or i reveal the magic you're isolating
yourself to zoom out further to make the
room feel bigger i think and so in that
negative space there on the outside of
the room it's either like being propped
up or you're being handed it yeah the
last part is right i'm being handed it
it's just my
good old dad just sitting in the corner
and like swinging it in
well it's tough because well first of
all there's a thing on the wall which
i'm always struggling against there's
like a decorative lamp on the wall
installed on there so it's hard for me
to take it off so it's not a set it's
yeah it's a room in my in my parents
house that
i had been filming in from the beginning
when i had lived there so i just go back
to film there
there's like a janky sort of shadow of
me ending there because i was trying to
digitally paint that out so i'm like
reconstructing a bit of that shadow for
the moment that it's being swung in and
then it's just there a lot of people i'm
sure who are aspiring to do visual
effects watch your stuff and you've
probably inspired a lot of people to get
into visual effects and visual trickery
would you have any advice those people
who are trying to go out there and do
their own thing i would say like my own
experience i went to film school i went
to be a filmmaker some people say don't
bother with film school i thought it
worked for me like i feel like that
hands-on experience is the only place i
could have done that but
vfx stuff i do feel especially today
like you could just get into it on your
own there's plenty of resources out
there
plenty of courses plenty of free youtube
videos it's really where you take it
from there like some people turn it into
a big like empire of doing cool visual
effects and cool projects and some
people you know they'll do a couple more
pose videos and then they'll they'll
move on to becoming an accountant or
something so it's really just like how
are you going to climb that like
whatever you achieve just experiment
play with things and keep learning i
think what you've done
is kind of in a way the end goal of what
a lot of people actually aspire to do
which is creating something
that moves other people and you've now
established a direct connection
with you as the artist and the audience
that wants your art i do catch myself
sometimes going like ah you know the
thing i'm doing that's not that great
but like you do have to keep in mind
like because i have an audience like
they appreciate
the thing i make it's almost like you
build
what you are by like seeing how people
are reacting how your audience is
reacting to you and like what else are
we really doing it for
guys and gals today's episode is brought
to you by squarespace now if you are an
entrepreneur creator maybe you have a
small business maybe you just want to
get a website out there so you can get
your product or your name or your brand
out there well guess what courtesy of
today's sponsor squarespace we have one
of the best ways for you to do that
squarespace has been around for years
and all they do is create beautiful
award-winning templates with 24 7
award-winning customer service so that
without knowing anything about a website
you can create something magnificent
squarespace has a members area feature
which allows you to put a gated area for
content on your site and allow members
to access that however you want they've
got connected social media accounts
meaning that you can make one post from
your squarespace website and have that
automatically go out and format to
multiple different social media
platforms they allow multiple
contributors so if you have a small team
or maybe even a large team you can give
different people different levels of
access to contribute to your site they
also have video blocks and audio blocks
which allow you to embed video content
and audio content into your site and to
have that content go out into the world
however and wherever you need it and
last but not least squarespace gives you
some of the best traffic overviews tools
in the game they give you insights on
data where your people are coming from
how they're engaging with your site and
the experience that you are offering to
them when you start to understand this
you can continue to make a better and
better website and with all these
magnificent tools squarespace allows you
to do that conveniently easily and
without a team of developers to develop
a site for you that's what they're for
they've done it they already have a team
of developers just ask them so if you
guys are interested in getting started
for yourself head on over to
squarespace.comcrew and you can get 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain so anyways thanks for listening
thanks for watching and thanks to
squarespace for always coming through on
this channel they're a huge amazing
sponsor let's get back to that captain d
[Music]
alright so since we have captain
disillusion on the couch
i think it's important that we ask for
you
leave a comment for other visual effects
magicians that are out there whether
it's on youtube tick tock old vines
whatever you can find obscure stuff
that's worthy of my debunking talents
i'd appreciate that
heck yeah leave a comment if you think
these episodes are too short well you're
in luck at corridor digital.com we have
extended episodes and also if you're
more of a friday night vfx artist react
kind of person
all episodes come out the day before and
son of a dungeon is also finished oh
yeah we also made this huge show called
son of a dungeon it's a d d show that
got turned into like basically a game of
thrones style season of fantasy action
guess what it's only 3.99 a month
there's also a two-week free trial stop
it i'm subscribing now please stop it
alan i've watched your stuff for years i
really respect how long you've been
doing it for i feel like we're kind of
brothers in that sense that we've also
been on youtube doing visual effects for
years we've seen the world change around
us we're still holding on to our ways
keeping them alive it's been an absolute
honor and a pleasure to have you join us
on the show so thank you thank you so
much guys it's been a real pleasure i'm
not intimidated at all it's been awesome
well that's it for the bucket list yeah
what are you all gonna be telling me
every single day in my inbox to guest on
now nothing my life's work is complete
no you're just gonna go you're gonna fly
back and then they'll be like what are
you doing go but get back there
yeah thank you i would love it really
enjoyed this sweet well thank you so
much see you guys in the next one this
isn't a brand integration i just want to
tell you that we have a bunch of new
incredible merchandise in corridor
digital dot store just in time for
christmas including but not limited to
the incredible new bomber jacket we
spent a year in development on this
jacket we got a whole new design from
the look style fit and texture gabe made
an incredible map design that goes on
the inside of the jacket and we have
only a limited number that are only
available right now we've got a bunch of
other new stuff in store too including
women's cuts brand new hats like this
one right here with this cool corridor
digital tag right on the inside brand
new book bags so head on over to
quarterdigital.store and don't forget if
you're a member of quarterdigital.com
you get 15 off all merch all the time
and first dibs just another reason to be
subscribed to the site but if you're not
don't worry there's still going to be
some stuff left for you but you got to
get in there quick anyways i just want
to let you know it's the best way to
support us if you're not subscribed to
our website so
that's it enjoy bye